the hilarious and critically acclaimed
mitchells versus the machines
is so positively bursting with easter
eggs in jokes and film references that
you might wear out your pause button
trying to spot them all
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing over a hundred crazy
details and secrets hidden in the
mitchells versus the machines
some spoilers ahead so take care the
movie kicks off with a cell phone being
crushed beneath the foot of a pal robot
referencing the famous scene from the
90's robot apocalypse movie terminator 2
judgement day of a skull being crushed
underfoot by a killer bot
powell the name of the operating system
and digital personal assistant who
orchestrates the robopocalypse after
being tossed aside by a human creator is
a reference to hal 9000 the ai
antagonist from stanley kubrick's epic
sci-fi
2001 a space odyssey who also turned
against his human operators when he
discovered they planned to disconnect
him
the red dot on each of the pal robot's
heads is also a nod to house depiction
as a camera lens with a red dot in the
middle
and at the dino stop when katie orders
the two pal robots not to take them
the dot on their head changes from red
to blue to subtly signal their change in
character from antagonists
to the more helpful robots they turn out
to be pal
also has the feel of the mega tech
company apple
and the shiny pal retail store the
mitchell's visit in the mall has apple
store vibes
and coincidentally or not if you
rearrange the letters in pal to apl
it very much sounds like apple when pal
is revealed to her creator mark as the
villain at the heart of the robot
conspiracy the evil cell phone swivels
round on her chair
and you can see she's sitting on a small
pile of books
the top one is the master algorithm
which examines machine learning and
predicts the rise of a master algorithm
that will come to a perfect
understanding of the world and humanity
in the middle is the art of war the
ancient treaties that has influenced
both military and business strategy and
tactics across the world
and the book at the base of the pile is
titled the singularity is near
another real-life book whose author
predicts that machine intelligence will
eventually surpass human intelligence
and bring about a technological
singularity
an event which comes to pass in the
mitchell's movie
the look of the movie's sleek white
robots draws on honda's humanoid robot
asimo which was created in the year 2000
and named after sci-fi writer
isaac asimov which is especially fitting
because the scenes of marching robot
armies remind me of both the movie
irobot starring will smith and the
stormtroopers from star wars
by the way the filmmakers have said the
robots use a fully developed robot
language which contains secret jokes for
anyone who can crack it
you can see the robots using it as they
type to figure out the code look closely
at the scenes of the robots taking over
different cities around the world
and you can see how each city's name is
translated into the robot
language one of the best moments in the
movie comes when the mitchells were
attacked by a mass of pal-chipped
machines and take cover in a toy store
only then to be confronted by a
horrifying army of furbies who begin to
talk in their own language
this furby form of communication is
referencing the original furby toys who
when newly purchased spoke a language
called
furbish and were programmed to only
begin to speak english gradually each
time they were turned on
in the mitchells the furby's
vocalizations are suitably horrifying
hilarious and creepy at the same time
the mitchell's dog monchi with his
ability to make the robot's error and
explode turns out to be one of the mvps
of the movie
dog shield activate dog dog loaf of
bread
system
celebrity dog doug the pug who has
millions of followers online
provided munchies barks grunts sneezes
snores licks and other assorted canine
noises
while munchie's character look and name
were inspired by monchichi the equally
excitable warlie
dog of writer director mike reander's
sister the zany style of the mitchells
is truly phenomenal thanks to the
animators being encouraged to embrace
their wildest
impulses during production because most
of the movie is told from the
perspective of katie who's a filmmaker
herself
the animators created something they
called katie vision
which is where her creativity and
emotions spill out onto the screen
the idea was that it should feel as if
katie edited the movie herself
so you have 2d doodles and drawings as
well as internet mashups memes and
filters popping up on top of the 3d
animation
revealing more details about katy's
character and feelings within a scene
interestingly some of the freedom to
experiment on this film came from the
success of spider-man into the
spider-verse as both movies were
produced by phil lord and chris miller
because katie's a filmmaker almost
everything associated with her as a
movie reference or easter egg
for example look really carefully at
katie's socks and you'll see they have
the same hexagonal orange brown and red
pattern
as the iconic carpet from the overlook
hotel in the shining
and in some real attention to detail
those shining socks even appear when
katie transforms the columbia lady logo
into her own likeness at the very start
of the film
and while characters from her various
home movies rain down from the sky
the fact that some of them are food
really brings to mind cloudy with a
chance of meatballs directed by lorda
miller the producers of this movie
the bomb-shaped pin on katie's hoodie is
another stanley kubrick reference to his
1960s cold war satire dr strangelove and
like the bomb in that film
katie's pin has the words hi there
written on it also on her hoodie are
pins of munchie
the logo for the california college of
film where she's been accepted to study
and a rainbow pin and a bit of
foreshadowing to the reveal of katie's
girlfriend at the end of the movie
and the lawn wrangler's pin on her
backpack is a reference to wes
anderson's first feature film the crime
comedy bottle rocket
some cool genre movie posters in katie's
room include horror legend boris karloff
snake people the zombie sci-fi creature
with the atom brain
the monster movie it came from beneath
the sea and robo slayers four
and the title seems to be a clever
reference to the mitchell's own story
about a family of four who defeat a
robot uprising
the movie's subtitled rise of the brain
exploders is also a reference to how the
mitchells use monchi to cause the robots
to malfunction and self-combust
and another funny detail on the dvd is
where it says it's brought to you by the
visionary director of zombie flesh
picnic and werewolf war criminal
for her application to film school katie
creates her own personal mount rushmore
of director heroes which includes lady
bird director greta gerwig
french filmmaker saline siama lynn
ramsey whose most recent feature was you
were never really here
and harold and moore director hal ashby
and there are some neat tributes in
casey's own assortment of short films to
some of those directors
so her portrait of an idiot on fire is a
nod to siama's historical romantic drama
portrays the lady on fire
well going there references hal ashby's
being there starring peter sellers
there's dial b for burger her homage to
alfred hitchcock's crime thriller dial
m for murder and two hilarious looking
sequels dalby for burger 2
diagnosis which as we can see from the
injured burger on the thumbnail follows
up on the events of the first film where
monty chomped down on the talking bun
razzle dazzle
and the final film in the trilogy is
darl b for burger 3
forgiveness where it seems the burger on
his deathbed forgives monchie
the perks of having only one friend as a
play on the coming-of-age drama the
perks of being a wallflower plus katie's
feelings of being an outsider i've
always felt a little
different than everyone else while katie
and aaron is the mitchell family spin on
the oscar-winning road movie thelma and
louise
as for monchi fear eats the soul that's
a riff on the mid-70s film that brought
german filmmaker rayna verna fassbinder
his first
international success they lived in the
jurassic period
is a dinosaur-inspired parody of john
carpenter's 80s movie they live where
aliens disguised as humans ruled the
world
i have come here to chew bubblegum
and kick ass and i'm all out above them
and there's even an amusing riff on that
famous line in one of katie's good cop
dog cop films i'm here to bust criminals
and lick my own butt
and i'm all out of criminals and there's
also katie's director on director q
a which sees her brother kitted out in
the inimitable style of new wave
director anias vada
some other interesting film titles on
the screen are oops a wizard transformed
us into chickens which seems like it's
riffing on honey ice frank the kids
chloe will you go to prom might be a
video promposal
another hint to katie being lgbtq plus
and there's lots more interesting
details in katie's good cop dog cop
movies
her brother who stars as a hardened
criminal drives a car with a perfectly
fitting license
plate crimes some cool canine touches in
the dog cop
movie that mark watches are a missing
poster for a ball
a wanted poster for a squirrel a stolen
poster for a pair of slippers and the
motto on the precinct's wall is to
protect and serve
kibble pictures of other dog favorite
objects also adorn the walls including a
fire hydrant and a bone
during their time barricaded in the dino
stop the post-apocalyptic world of the
mad max franchise gets a shout out in
katie's dope plan to defeat the robots
make a necklace out of robot fingers mad
max now and become
world-saving apocalyptic road warriors
when the mitchells rock up to the mall
of the globe
katie name checks the second movie and
writer director george romero's iconic
zombie film series
this is like dawn of the dead yeah and
how'd that movie end
after the mitchell's layout their plan
to take down pal on her home turf then
celebrate there's a fun scene transition
in the style of the 1960s batman tv show
mitchell's engage and as powell tries to
figure out how to stop the mitchells
there's a funny freeze frame moment when
she orders the robots to pull up all the
family's flaws
an absolute barrage of details pop up on
screen
including once brought up his favorite
rib during a eulogy
looks at ex-boyfriend carlo maloney on
facebook more than it's comfortable
which given the svu references elsewhere
in katy's films makes me wonder if this
is a wink to form a law and order svu
star christopher maloney
and those family flaws continue with
only pretends to like fellini
kicked out of an olive garden for
stashing breads in purse
showers with shocking rarity doctor
diagnosed chocoholic
and eats own weight in cheese puffs each
month and pal also brings up much more
of the mitchell's online activity
including aaron's dinosaur obsessed
search history with him asking questions
such as whether dinosaurs kiss
and how to get paleontologists to reply
to your emails
then there's this crush on the girl next
door with searches such as does abby
posey have a boyfriend and what is love
mum linda's inbox has revealing email
titles such as
parent teacher night apology incident
with your son and a lifetime ban from
what looks like a best buy
it's almost like stealing people's data
and giving it to a hyper-intelligent ai
as part of an unregulated tech monopoly
was a bad thing
of course despite being what katie
describes as the worst family of all
time the mitchells do manage to save the
world though it's amusing how
incredulous the general reaction is with
the cover of people magazine saying
a nation asks these people really
just below their family that save the
world headline
on the other hand the aptly named posies
get a much more complementary write up
on the same cover
by the way given the posies perfect
online family vibe the filmmakers had
some fun casting model turn
tv personality and author chrissy teigen
and real-life husband
singer-songwriter john legend who are
also known for their social media
presence
while their dino-loving daughter abby is
voiced by actress comedian and writer
charlene yee
among the stack of films in katy's home
movie collection as itu papa tambien a
gender-swapped version of alfonso
quaron's hit coming-of-age film ito
mamatambien which like the mitchells
versus the machines is also a road movie
crowbar jones is a hat tip to the
in-universe film series of the same name
that
appears in the cartoon network animated
show wii burberres
raptor high is probably a nod to the
animated series clone high featuring
adolescent clones of famous historical
figures attending high school
the show was co-created by the
mitchell's producers lord and miller
fists of fury is an animal related
makeover of fists of fury starring bruce
lee
and pugs in space is a canine take on
the recurring muppet show sketch
pigs in space fear and loathing in
central
michigan is a reference to terry gilliam
sphere and lothie in las vegas with a
nod to katie's home state
owen notice how casey's dvds are marked
as the k
collection obviously pointing to her
first names initial but also as a hat
tip to the criterion collection and kino
home entertainment labels
given the mitchells are inspired by
co-writer director mike rienda's own
real-life family it seems fitting he
voices katie's younger brother aaron hi
would you like to talk to me about
dinosaurs
no okay thank you who's loosely based on
both rianda and his fellow writer
director jeff rowe when they were kids
and row also cameos in the movie is the
man at the dino stop who
really loves fun who here likes fun hey
i like fun
trust me bud you do not like fun no i
really do like it everyone says that
about me
you lucky human also at the dyno stop
row and rianda's first names pop up
among the nameplate signs in the gift
shop
another cameo in the mitchells is by
youtuber l mills who voices hannah one
of katie's film school friends
so good and speaking of katie's college
mates her fellow cinephile dirk foley is
voiced by alex hirsch who created
gravity falls the animated mystery
comedy series which both mitchell's
writers and directors mike riander and
jeff rowe worked on as well
mind-blowing by the way dirk's surname
is a filmmaking in-joke as foley is the
process of reproducing
everyday sound effects such as footsteps
opening doors or breaking glass which
are added into movies during
post-production
oh and katie's film books also contains
a hat tip to dan hanson who worked on
disney animations including aladdin and
hercules and also taught at cal arts
where this film's directors both studied
and became friends
and one of the mitchell cg supervisors
ben aguian also gets the name check as
writer of lights camera angst
suitably enough as he also supervised
the lighting team on spider-man into the
spider-verse
so i was completely blown away by the
animation and incredible details in the
mitchell's versus the machines but what
did you notice that i missed
let me know in the comments below and if
you enjoy discovering easter eggs and
other hidden details and animated movies
then tap
left for my full playlist or you can tap
right to check out something else you're
sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers